we should discuss quickly that you've
had a milestone sona you're you're twins
are now one year old i kept my two boys
alive for a year
it really does feel like that i remember
i remembered my wife
saying the same thing about our daughter
nev when she
hit one year old my my wife turned to me
and said i kept her alive for a year
yeah so i completely understand that
yeah especially now when you're you're
not there's two of them too so you're
not always looking at them and then
sometimes you'll look over and one will
have a full-on twig in his mouth just
eating it or like you know a rock that
they're just eating once where do they
get a hold of these twigs and rocks are
they are you in the house or outside of
the house you're chill outside you're
feeding your kids kids
that's not the twig i gave you to eat
one time i was in the same room with
them and they opened up the glass
sliding door and they crawled outside
and i didn't know until i heard mikey
squeal with just laughter and i i look
over and they're not in the house at all
they've just fully crawled i was in the
same room with them so this is why i'm
really then you hear a car start up them
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's hilarious yeah it'll always make
me laugh when
either a little child wanders off camera
and there's a pause or an animal wanders
and then you hear a car start up
it just always cracks me up when a puppy
rounds the corner then you hear a car
start off yeah yeah yeah yeah but your
your feelings toward charlie haven't
gotten any better and i think that i
have beef with charlie yeah but it's
it's been months and he's a one-year-old
but every time you're like how's mikey
doing i'm like i have two kids
i intentionally only ask how mikey is
because charlie didn't laugh
when i was doing my shtick and man was
out working it
he wasn't going for it so i decided all
right uh i'm just we're not this isn't
happening he's dead to you he's dead to
me he was so little he was a little baby
so what he dissed me and uh it's up to
him to make it's up to him to settle the
beef he's gonna drive to your house and
settle
well congratulations that's a big deal
thank you very much but now they can
move and walk i remember because it's i
remember very clearly when you told me
that the babies had been born because in
the womb i didn't know what to call them
i called them rub and tug you did we've
we've never really discussed this but
you called my babies rub and tug yeah
because they didn't have names yet and
then you said i've given them these
great old ancestral armenian names mikey
and charlie
when you guys saw them did you just say
this one's a mikey and this one's a
charlie you had those names ready to go
no no i think someone had to tack the
paperwork and he panicked and just put
those two names i'm not even kidding we
didn't know what we were going to name
them and then he just wrote there's
those names down on
wait what that's how
you came up with the game discuss those
names we talked about certain names but
we hadn't settled on them and then i
walked in and he's filling out paperwork
and i said are you writing names down he
goes yeah and i'm like which which names
he also wrote down their religion as
islam oh i panicked
i just wrote islam hey for city of birth
you wrote
akron ohio i i just panicked
wait this these aren't their footprints
that you put in there i know i panicked
i used our cat's paw print
and our drawables footprint
i just panicked
he said right here occupation astronaut
an oil speculator i panicked
i painted it i thought i had to write
something so i wrote it down
i would love that if all these crucial
things
were handled by
hey our kids are going to the military
academy
they're only i panicked
i panicked i just they're going to west
point they're five tack
i panicked
i panicked
oh man it is it's fun and and glenn's
not far behind because she's exactly
three months younger than the boy yeah
she's nine months now nine months and
acting every day of it
well
i wasn't around for the raising of my
children
that's probably the best i had
i had a career to tend to
you have a podcast to tend to exactly
drawing i said i know i'm drawing a
little guy
there's a rap sign for you thanks a lot
there buddy